PROFESSOR: So now we come
to an interesting variant
of ordinary induction
called strong induction,
and here's how it works.
With strong induction, just
as with ordinary induction,
you prove the base case P of 0.
You're trying to prove for all
nP of n, so you prove P of 0,
but now in order to prove P of
n plus 1 in the inductive step,
assuming P of n with
ordinary induction,
with strong induction you
can assume not just P of n
but you can assume
P of 0, P of 1.
All the properties-- that
all the numbers up through n
have the property.
And from this, of
course, you could
conclude that that
everything has the property
that for all mP of m.
Now, an intuitive way
to justify this is you
think about it the way
that induction works is
you start off at 0, and
then you make a step to 1,
and you make another step to 2,
and you make another step to 3,
and the induction step
going from n to n plus 1
justifies each of those steps.
By the time you get
to n and you have
to prove you can
get to n plus 1,
you've already been
through 0 1 up to n.
You might as well take
advantage of that fact.
Instead of only remembering
that you're at the n step,
you might as well remember
that you got there.
That's an intuitive
hand-wavy argument
which can be justified
formally in a way that will
emerge in the next segment.
So let's hold off on that
and just bite the bullet
and accept this as a
basic principle of math
that we're going to
live with and use.
As an application of it,
let's prove something
that we've already proved by
well ordering and, in fact,
strong induction and well
ordering are closely related,
as we'll also discuss later.
So let's prove that using
$0.03 and $0.05 stamps that you
can get any amount of
postage greater than
or equal to $0.08 stamps,
and I'm going to prove this
by strong induction,
with the induction
hypothesis P of n that says I
can form n plus $0.8 stamps.
Clearly, if I can
prove for all nP of n,
then I've proved that I can get
for every amount greater than
or equal to $0.08 stamps.
And let's do the base case.
Well, the base case, P of 0.
Can I make $0.8 stamps?
Sure, $0.03 and $0.05.
That's that one, and that's OK.
For the inductive
step, I have to get
m-- I'm allowed
to assume, rather,
that I can get m plus
$0.8 for any m from n
down to 0, instead
of just assuming
that I can get n plus $0.8
to get n plus 1 plus $0.08.
I can assume any amount less
than what I'm aiming for,
so I may as well assume that I
can get any amount of postage
from $0.08 up to n plus
$0.08, and my objective then
is to get n plus 1 plus
$0.08, namely n plus $0.09.
So I have to prove that for all
n greater than or equal to 0,
I can get n plus $0.09,
assuming I can get from $0.08
to n plus $0.08.
Well, that's not too hard to do.
The inductive step
is actually going
to break up into
a couple of cases,
depending on the value of n.
I have to prove n plus $0.09 for
all n, so suppose n equals 0,
I have to get $0.09.
Well, three $0.03.
If n is 1, I have to get 1
plus $0.09 or $0.10, two $0.05.
So those cases are disposed of.
So now my job is to get
n plus $0.09, where n
is greater than or equal to 2.
Well, the nice
thing about n being
greater than or equal to 2 is
that if I subtract 2 from it,
it's a smaller number, and
it's still not negative,
and that means that I can get
that amount plus $0.08 stamps.
So I'm in this nice situation
where I, by strong induction,
I can get n minus 2
plus $0.08 stamps.
There they are.
And how do I get to n plus 9?
Well, it's easy.
I add a $0.03
stamp, and you have
n plus $0.09, which completes
the proof of the induction
case, and the whole
theorem is proved.
We can conclude then
that it works for all n
and that you can indeed
get n plus $0.08 using
$0.03 and $0.05 stamps
for all of them.
So much for that example.
All right, let's look
at another example.
This is a game that we
used to play in class.
You start off with a stack
of blocks, say 10 blocks,
and you're allowed
to make a move that
consists of splitting the
stack into two smaller stacks.
So if the stack has
height a plus b,
you can split it into a
stack of height a and a stack
of height b, and you get
a score for that move.
The score is a times b.
And then you keep doing that
until you can't make anymore
moves.
That is, when all you have
left are stacks of height one,
which you can't split anymore,
and then your overall score
is the total that you
got for all the moves
that you made until that point.
Now, when we played
this in class,
we would have
students competing,
and they would try
various strategies.
So one strategy-- the simplest
strategy, maybe not the best,
but the simplest
strategy, would be
to start off with a stack
of 10, so you take one of,
and that leaves you with
a stack of one and nine.
Your score is nine.
Then you take another one
off of the stack of nine,
and you're left with
a one and an eight.
Your score is eight, and so
on, and you can see, in fact,
if took one-at-a-time process
then your score with a stack
of height n would be n
minus 1 plus n minus 2,
down to 2 plus 1.
Another strategy that
might be sort of more
in the spirit of
computer science
would be to keep
splitting in two.
So for example, if you
had a stack of height 10,
you could split
it into two fives,
and then you take
one of the fives
and split it into
three and a two,
and then you'd split
the two into two ones,
and so on, splitting as
evenly as you can each time,
and it seems like it might
be a better strategy.
And, again, we
would have students
try various strategies,
and guess what?
They all came in in
a tie, and that's
what we're going to prove now.
Every way of unstacking n
blocks gives the same score.
Well, what score?
Well, we know that the score for
the simple strategy of taking
one block off at a time is
the sum from 1 to n minus 1,
and that has a nice formula--
n times n minus 1 over 2,
so we can formulate our claim
that no matter how you play
the unstacking game with
the stack of size n,
your final score will be
n times n minus 1 over 2,
and we're going to prove
this by strong induction,
with this statement--
call it claim of n--
is going to be the
induction hypothesis.
That's what we're
trying to prove.
Well, let's start
in the usual way.
The base case is n equals 0.
Well, you might be bothered.
That's no blocks.
Well, let's see what happens.
With no blocks, the score is 0
because there's nothing to do,
and indeed the formula that
is alleged to be your score
comes out to be 0, so the
base case n equals 0 works.
Let's continue.
For the inductive case, I have
to assume that the given score
formula holds for all
stacks of height n or less,
and I have to
prove that it holds
for a stack of height n plus 1.
That is, that an n
plus 1 stack score
is n plus 1 times n over 2.
Well, how shall I do that?
Well, I'm going to split the
inductive case into two cases.
It turns out that I need
to prove that c of n plus 1
holds, assuming c of n for n and
less than n but, in particular,
let's just deal with
the case that n plus 1
is 1, the smallest value
it could have and knock
that one off separately.
Namely, if the stack
is of height one,
again my score is 0, because
there's no move to make,
and the formula
still evaluates to 0.
So in the case that n plus 1 is
1, I've proved the claim at n
plus 1, which I was
obligated to do for the base
case-- for the inductive step.
Well, the other case in the
inductive step is that n plus 1
is greater than 1.
This is the interesting
one, because now it's
possible to make a move.
So since n plus 1
is greater than 1,
it's two or more blocks.
I can make a move
into two stacks
that are both of positive.
So suppose I do that?
Suppose I split the
stack of size n plus 1
into an a stack and a b stack,
where a and b sum to n plus 1.
And what's my score
going to be then?
Well, my score on
that move that I make,
where I split into the a
stack and the b stack is a b,
and the rest of
the game consists
of playing as well as
I can on the a stack
and as well as I
can on the b stack,
but a and b are
smaller than n plus 1.
They're less than
or equal to n, which
means that by strong induction,
I know that no matter how
I play on the a stack,
I'm going to wind up
with this score a
times a minus 1 over 2.
No matter how I
play on the b stack,
I'm going to wind up with
b times b minus 1 over 2,
so that means that my
score on a plus b stack
is going to be this formula, ab
plus a times a minus 1 over 2
plus b times b minus 1 over 2.
So you simplify
that to organize it
so it's a plus b times a plus
b minus 1, which is exactly
n plus 1 times n
over 2, which is
what we were trying to prove.
We've proved C event plus 1.
The inductive step is
complete, and indeed we've
proved that no matter
how big the stack is,
your score comes out the same.